نتابع هذه الطالب بعدما اقتحم وزير الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي يتمرمن غفير ساحات
المسجد الاقصى صباح اليوم وجاء اقتحام من
بنك كثير لباحات الاقصى تحت حمايه امنيه
مشدده وقالبا كثير ان جبل الهيكل في اشاره
للحرم الشريف هو روح الشعب اليهودي وانه
سيبقى تحت السياده الاسرائيليه الى الابد
وقد حضرت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه من ان
اقتحامتير لساحات المسجد الاقصى صباح
اليوم ستكون له تداعيات خطيره ومن جهه
قالت حركه حماس ان هذا الاقتحام يؤكد عمق
الخطر المحدق بالاقصى في ظل الحكومه
المتطرفه الاسرائيليه مؤكده ان الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يترك المسجد الاقصى وحيدا
بدورها
وتصعيد الخطير اول مرفوض وبالخرق الفاضح
للقانون الدولي وللوضع التاريخي والقانوني
القائمي في القدس
بدك تصيب اكاغوف خياط